[Musique]
ouf quelle journée
bonsoir les enfants je suis sûr que vous
avez été très gentils aujourd'hui et que
vous vous êtes bien amusé où êtes vous
allé à la campagne au jardin ou ou et
nous sommes allés à la campagne et gros
ours est très fier il a rapporté une
jolie colombes tout blanc genou ou ou
ceux pour la petite mirabelle et p'tit
louis le web alors ne soyez pas trop
longs monsieur rose au problème a permis
non c'est la mienne volonté les six lacs
et nos jardins ou solomon kane et les
bleus vous envoient leurs ovules à
menacer les bleus rapporte une surprise
pour les enfants sa jeunesse
on est un peu j'ai planté des fleurs
j'ai fait un grand château dans le sol
et j'ai coupé une heure puis on a toi en
vue même vos souliers surprise
fermez les yeux et compté jusqu'à 3
[Musique]
attention ce ailleurs ce qui c'est beau
mais c'est un grand pigeon non c'est une
petite colombe que j'ai rapporté de la
campagne pour la fête de votre maman au
oui alors regrette contente
d'ici là nous notre maman tous les soirs
quand on est couché conte de paix
reviendra dans notre lit elle nous donne
des musées oui c'est vrai tu crois non
ce que toutes les mamans elles sont
comme ça
bien sûr tous les soirs quand les petits
enfants dorment
elles viennent fermer les volets bordés
leur lit et leur donner un baiser
ma maman à moi elle le faisait chaque
soir nous promet souhaiter bonne fête
aujourd'hui
depuis l'un des dragons temps il a
pleuré on lui a fait des tas cadeau et
on vient donner de très belles fleurs
avec notre papa c'est très bien mes
enfants c'est très bien mais à présent
les leurs de faire dodo est encore une
toute petite minute où vas tu lire la
jolie carte gratuite
gratuit oui petite maman voici des
fleurs avec notre coeur
bonne fête maman bonne fête maman
bonne nuit les petits à demain va news
dors bien
annie mirabel de nuit qui lui
[Musique]
bonne fête à toutes les mamans
bonne fête bob fait bonne nuit les
enfants continuer à être bien sage et à
être toujours très gentil avec votre
maman alors nounours en route
à demain à demain
[Musique]